welcome back everybody famed Hollywood
actor and director Warren Beatty is
facing accusations that he coerced a 14
year old girl to have sex with him 50
years ago a Louisiana Woman Christina
Charlotte Hirsch filed the complaint
against defendant doe but the documents
make it very clear that she is referring
to Warren Beatty her says she first met
the defendant on a movie set in 1973
when she was 14 and Beatty was 35 and
she says that the actor used his power
and influence to convince her to visit
him in his hotel and eventually have sex
with him the filing says that Hirsch
suffered physical injuries then and
still suffers psychologically
emotionally and mentally now a
California law actually allows adult
survivors of childhood sexual assault to
file lawsuits within 22 years of them
reaching adult age or within five years
of discovering that an injury or illness
is related to a past sexual assault
Brian I think this is fascinating but
this happened 50 years ago do you think
that this lawsuit is really going to go
anywhere or was it filed to make more of
a symbolic message I think it'd be on
set at the very least it has some legs
to stand on now Hirsch is following a
suit using a 2019 California law uh
giving a three-year look back window for
claims of child sexual abuse past the
statue of limitations that window
interestingly enough actually ends
January 1st of 2023 so she had to get
this in now before the new law sexual
assault claims were brought in a similar
fashion as you described now baby was
was it actually named the suit but it's
absolutely clear that Hirsch meant to
name him because she said the defendant
as being a person nominated for an
Academy Award for his role as Clyde and
Bonnie and Clyde Hurst said that she met
the defendant as you said on a movie
theater and that because of this undue
attention giving her her number he
called multiple times she's actually
saying that Warren groomed manipulated
exploited and coerced her into sexual
contact all of those are typical
allegations in a case like like this now
Warren Beatty he would have been 35 at
the time she's 14 or 15. that's
statutory rape she says at the time she
was thrilled by the attention and she's
now seeking damages I can see the
defense saying hey this is byra's
remorse because they're not going to be
on the hook for statutory rape because
this is a slightly different situation
but still bad nonetheless she's saying
that she's having difficulty interacting
with people of authority and issues of
trust and control the claims seemed to
be pretty serious Jesse especially with
this new law but the question that I
would have is can she Prevail at trial
with a case this old and with these
facts well Terry let's play it out
assuming this case moves so forward how
can Hersh really explain the delay in
coming forward with her claims you know
she's going to have to explain it
because 50 years is a very long time and
I think what they're going to have to do
is put an expert on that stand they did
that in the Harvey Weinstein case they
said that Dr Barbara ziv she's a
forensic psychiatrist they could do
something like that he here as well and
I think what the doctor if they put
someone on the stand would ultimately
say is look she was a child she was 14.
she probably thought she would get in
trouble it was someone she knew she
probably didn't even know what rape is
or what sexual assault is so if you have
an expert who can come on the stand and
explain all of that I definitely think
it's going to help the case so I think
they're going to call some experts and I
doubt very seriously if she herself will
get on the stand Terry I mean if this
does go to a trial is he going to
testify and what would he say it's a
good question I think he could get on
that stand he's going to probably have
to explain you know that it never
happened obviously he can't talk about
consent because she was 14 at the time
but he will probably try to explain or
his lawyers will that it didn't happen
that she mistakenly identified him we
saw that that just happened in the case
against dershowitz where there was a
mistaken identity so something like that
could really happen if in fact baby is
able to prove look I wasn't there and
she's wrong I think she's making a
mistake what a case I'm really curious
to see how that one plays out